how much cash do you have on you right
now mmm maybe like $2,500 really yeah
can I see it can you see I think you
know that's just s day can see emergency
cash this is with Maya it's good blues
let's just listen maybe she can't this
is just in case anything happens this is
a new hundred they only give rappers
it's the will give you a new first what
is happening right now
yeah the new ones are pretty crazy
that's a lot of money um it's a nice
it's a day's worth of emergencies did
you specifically join a music like the
music you make to get laid I was
watching a video your hit single and I
was like what is happening how did they
even finish shooting this without just
everybody yeah everyone to like 4:00
a.m. and it was definitely a very a
tinting video so like yeah you have to
look at your Reagan no but I do I
believe this is uh one of my mom's
co-workers who was my age though cuz she
acted like a daycare do you remember yes
Lucretia she was Hispanic and she was
from the ghetto ha ha ha ha
anything stupid that you're afraid of
huh um I'm not afraid of much
I think I'm afraid of heights but like
if you dare me to do something I'll do
it I love it but like dare you to give
me $2,800 don't be a [ __ ]
Yeah right everybody get out of this
room now but uh besides that no Heights
is a good one Heights is legit hi Santa
Restless guess those are two great
answers yes about it man you know they
can use little and right to make you
itch like that ship no that's why I
gotta wear bag those STD tarantulas
weirdest doctor ever and I got those
dick tarantulas she has it
do you know Lucretia I'm sure she's
watching but kidding honestly one of the
coolest guys I know so talented thanks
for being here man
definitely kidding check him out watch
up on the back by the Lord